-Today is Friday,
and that's usually when
I catch up on some
personal stuff.
You know, I check my inbox,
I return some e-mails,
and of course, I send out
thank you notes,
and I was running a bit behind.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thanks for letting me
write some notes tonight.
James, can I get some thank you
note writing music, please?
[ Gentle music plays ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Is he okay?
-Great mood tonight.
-Yeah, wow.
-Here we go. [ Clears throat ]
[ Gentle music plays ]
Thank you, hay rides,
for giving kids the chance
to experience
how fun it is to be hay.
[ Applause ]
Go on rides all the time.
-Come on.
-It's cool, man.
-Be-hay-ve.
[ Laughter ]
-Hayyy.
[ Gentle music plays ]
Thank you, answering someone's
texts with a thumbs up,
for saying, "this is where
the conversation ends."
[ Applause ]
We're good.
Yeah, yeah. Sure, sure.
-Thumbs up.
-We're good.
[ Gentle music plays ]
Thank you, apple picking,
for somehow costing
five times more
than when someone else
does it for you.
[ Applause ]
I picked these.
I picked these!
They're 20 times more than I
would normally buy at the store.
-At Whole Foods, too.
-Yeah, man.
-$300 for an apple?
Pretty steep.
[ Gentle music plays ]
-Thank you, matchsticks,
for being toothpicks that
got their nails done.
Oh!
[ Applause ]
Good.
-That's a cute one.
[ Audience member laughs ]
[ Gentle music plays ]
-That's a good laugh.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
That's a great laugh, yeah.
-That's beautiful.
-It's a good laughing crowd.
I love this crowd.
-It's a good Friday crowd.
-What's that?
Don't ruin it.
We're having a good thing.
[ Applause ]
-I didn't hear you.
What'd you say?
[ Laughter ]
-I said New York City is
the best city in the world!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what I said!
Alright, here we go.
[ Gentle music plays ]
Thank you, chicken nuggets
and fish sticks,
for not making it awkward
when you
showed up to the party
in the same outfit.
It's like, oh!
[ Applause ]
Really?
[ Gentle music plays ]
Thank you, leaf blowers,
for being there whenever
I want to
make my problem
someone else's problem.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
"How you doing, Dave?"
-"6:00 in the morning, Dave."
[ Laughter ]
-"This is gas-powered, too.
I don't know if you can tell."
[ Imitates leaf blower ]
"Took the engine from
my son's dirt bike
and put it on the leaf blower."
-"Took off the muffler
to give it more torque."
-"I took off the muffler.
It just sounds cooler."
-[ Imitates leaf blower ]
-"Hey, good morning, Dave.
Appreciate ya."
"Might want to step on
that paper bag
that's on fire on
your front porch."
[ Laughter ]
-"Put some sugar in
your gas tank, Dave.
Flat tires."
-"Dave, why don't you come over?
I want to give you a wedgie.
Come on, just turn around.
Alright, buddy.
Best neighbor ever."
-"3:00 in the morning, Dave!"
[ Laughter ]
-"It's 3:00 in the morning
somewhere, Dave!"
-[ Imitates leaf blower ]
[ Imitates leaf blower revving ]
-For blowing leaves?
-Yeah.
-Wow. Wow.
-Took his son's dirt bike.
So now his kid doesn't even
have a dirt bike.
-"He doesn't even need
to ride it, Dave.
He's having enough fun
on the internet,
playing robots or whatever.
Check this thing out."
[ Imitates leaf blower revving ]
-"Got a new chainsaw!"
[ Imitates chainsaw revving ]
[ Imitates leaf blower revving ]
[ Gentle music playing ]
Thank you, electrical outlets,
for being wall nostrils.
[ Applause ]
[ Chuckles ]
[ Gentle music playing ]
Thank you, cinnamon sticks,
for looking like you'd be
delivered by a raven
with news from the North.
[ Applause ]
"Mr. Fallon!"
-The tea!
-Spice the cider!